hello you agree with me that talking about machine learning
artificial intelligence without really building
is like you just making noise without an effect
so
I'm thinking about building a particular project on machine learning
but here's the thing
I have several consideration just to choose which project
one I don't want it to be too complicated
secondly I want to ensure that it is rich enough
to help us grasp the knowledge that we need
to face any project that comes our way
so the first on my list is spam filter
spam filter could be used on social media
could be used on the email
could be used on a business catalogue
whatever it is but here's the thing
it is something that we are used to already
it is something
or a model that tells a business or a user if something is fake
or if it's fishy or if it's something that is not really meaningful
and how we're gonna do that
of course we combine several technologies to help us do that quickly
but if not spam filter what else can we build
another machine learning model we can build is handwriting recognition
just imagine writing with your hand
with pen and the machine determine which letter it is
we can also try this one out
the third list is house pricing prediction
this will be a big win for the Realtors
people were in charge of selling houses and house valuation